en este campo cercano a París no se
prevén lluvias al menos en los próximos
ocho o diez días Este productor de trigo
está cada vez a más preocupado las pocas
gotas que cayeron el martes No servirán
de mucho y sus cultivos ella empiezan a
amarillear
en lugar de obtener cuatro o cinco
espigas de trigo en estas plantas
probablemente Solo obtendremos dos tres
o incluso una
este mes solo han llovido 5 mm cuando
normalmente llueve 10 veces más una
situación alarmante en toda Francia en
burdeos ha llovido un 26% menos de lo
habitual y en París hasta un 95 menos el
sábado el presidente Manuel Magón abordó
el tema en la feria agrícola de París
tenemos que mejorar la forma en que se
utiliza nuestra agua tenemos que
establecer estructuras en toda Francia
para permitir la retención de agua y
asegurarnos de que los agricultores
puedan operar y la nación necesita
tratar el agua de la misma manera que ha
venido tratando la energía una especie
de plan sobriedad Mientras tanto los
agricultores buscan variedades que
necesitan menos agua para prosperar
están probando nuevas semillas como la
avena o la alfalfa
la elección de la variedad es importante
hoy Gracias al fitomejoramiento las
variedades son mucho más resistentes
tolerantes y adaptables
el mes de marzo será crítico para los
agricultores y no hay garantías de que
vaya a ser menos seco